actually gonna see some there's gonna be
about a contextual bandit system that
we've been building at Microsoft for
last two to three years and this work
with a large number of colleagues and
research in and F's and some very
cooperative product teams who sort of
let us basically mess around with their
system while we got our details right
okay so just a very quick snapshot of
contextual bandit learning all the
probably most people are familiar with
it in some form or the other so what the
general setup right is there's an
underlying state of the world or which
will which we're going to call the
context we get to observe this thing
which is an action we get to observe the
reward on the chosen action there's not
reinforcement learning so my actions
have only consequences on the immediate
reward but they're not going to
transform my future state the next state
of the world will again be observed from
the from an exogenous process and this
interaction will go on
it is however like reinforcement
learning partial information so I will
get to observe only a feedback on the
chosen action and I do not get any
information about the other actions
costs the goal in general is to optimize
this feedback so for instance I'll call
the feedback reward for this
presentation so we were thinking of
maximizing the reward for the chosen
actions in particular we are trying to
learn policies right so we're we're
trying to learn decision rules that
basically picked actions given a context
such that those policies result in a
high expected reward or high cumulative
reward
okay so where does this come up this is
this is an actual example where the
system is currently being used so if you
go to amazon.com this is roughly I think
closer to currently out it keeps on
changing but all of these different
parts of the page they want to basically
they decide which new stories to put
there so you can of course like have a
global model that's just presenting the
same sort of stories to every person and
you can maybe even just do it very
editorially by looking at what sort of
popular and what's training and current
and so on but we have a lot more
information when a user arrives often
they're signed in so we have a bunch of
profile information we know what they've
sort of read in the past and liked and
so on and we have often a bunch of
demographic location and all this other
information that you can take into
account while deciding what new stories
to present to them they would find
interesting and then you can observe how
to respond maybe by looking for day
click maybe by how long they actually
spent reading the stories you pick and
so on right and we can whatever reward
metric we set along we can try and
optimize our strategy to yield the
desired user behavior and we can kind of
also formally think about what what the
contextual bandit assumption implies
here which is will roughly thinking of
users being independent of each other
which is hopefully a very reasonable
assumption to be making this problem
right that one user arrives and their
wizard has no influence whatsoever on
how another user if I even if I give
them a really crappy or a really great
experience that probably does not
directly impact the experience of the
next user that's the conduction band
racism shape
and that's not limited to news
recommendation so in general you
definitely applies to content
recommendation problems of all shapes
and sizes and that's kind of the most
maybe obvious fit you know but but
there's many other places where often
with various degrees of imperfection you
can try and model them as contextual
bandit problems anything specially with
like a lot of user interfaces being on
sort of phone and continuously or with
reasonable latency talking to cloud and
so on there there's just also very nice
chances that arise for various kinds of
adaptive UI personalization and UI
adaptation and that I think is a pretty
nice example as well so people have kind
of tried to build things that often
target specific verticals specific
applications or classes of applications
but the goal is you know we have this
general contextual bandit framework it's
seemingly is trying to capture all of
these things at once so can we do the
same thing just like we do that we have
a single formalism and theory that
addresses many problems can we also have
a single system that can address many
problems and solve all of them well at
once rather than designing one-off
systems
so remember what are the key think each
Allen just that we have to keep in mind
we know that we will receive feedback
only on the actions we've taken which
means we kind of need to explore we need
to try all the actions which we haven't
ruled out as poor just yet java showed
us yesterday sometimes we should
probably try them as well but let's
ignore that part so what's a good action
it depends on the context that I receive
and so that kind of suggests that we
need to try every plausibly good action
for every context which would sort of be
too much exploration if we do it naively
but we have to do it
we know we have to do some randomized
choice of actions possibly it doesn't
always have to be randomized but
I'll kind of talk about two classes of
questions in a moment for one of them
you really have to do randomization for
other one if we were only interested in
doing explore exploit we might be able
to get away with some upper confidence
palm type strategy but just kind of the
very high level idea is going to be that
in many cases this is this what the
world looks like that you know people
have built some sort of machine learned
a ssin rule to to drive their system and
the idea is going to be we'll try and
insert some small amount of
randomization hopefully on maybe on top
of this existing system or by kind of
doing maybe even something more per se
pervasive at the level of the types of
models they're using and so on and
that's gonna now lead to if they were
always showing for instance this space
relate a new story to a user before now
with some other probability that'll pick
a different new story to recommend and
so on we'll make sure that when we are
doing this randomization we actually
record not just the decisions we are
taking but also sort of the probability
distribution that we are inducing over
these distributions or at least the
probability with which we are choosing
the action that was recommended and
that's going to be so that I can now
concretely define the types of questions
that we are interested in answering
using such a system so in reinforcement
learning in general there are two types
of questions people like to answer
there's sort of the on policy setting on
policy question which is given a problem
instance and given that you have the
option of acting in the world how do you
quickly learn a good policy while
incurring small redirect and this
basically where most of the contextual
bandit algorithms focus right I'm going
to do some adaptive Explorer X flag and
quickly try and learn about policy
people often don't like it when you're
dynamically changing the behavior of
machine learning algorithms they kind of
get worried that you know something kind
of unexpected will happen that will
start driving system off the rails and
you're maybe you'll sort of have some
reinforcement of bad behavior and so
they often get nervous when we tell them
about the latest and greatest algorithms
to do these types of things they say no
no no
don't do this do this other thing
instead maybe collect some data first
let's do some machine learning on it in
the comfort of our clusters and we'll
you know once we've run that run the
resulting model through all sorts of
checks and balances we are willing to
deploy it so obviously you can just
ignore the fact that it's a sort of
reinforcement learning problem and just
take whatever data you have and treat it
as sort of supervised data which is what
people do very often but we actually
have a systematic formalism for doing
reinforcement learning once we've
collected data which is the off
policy-setting right which is just to
take data that's generated according to
some logging policy and then we can use
this data to basically produce an
estimate for the value of some other
target policy pi that I might want to
evaluate right and there's a very simple
way of doing this most classical one is
for instance inverse propensity scoring
what you do is so naively what you might
do is right you would say oh I will go
over my records every time so I have a
policy PI in mind every time I see a
match meaning I observed the reward of
PI's action I will accumulate them just
over those just over the matching
records obviously this is going to be a
bit bias some policies might get more
matches than others so if we correct for
the bias by basically dividing by the
probability of this event and that leads
to an easy and biased estimate and you
know we know we know a lot of political
properties about this one we have bunch
of improvements that have been proposed
in the literature or this one and we try
try to you use the improvements whenever
possible and so on but but that's kind
of the okay so that's that's that's the
picture of the questions we have what we
know about sort of from the from the
theory from the formalism side you go
and tell people that they should do this
they try their best often to do this and
it fails if therefore completely
reasons so you know there's like usually
these things are happening in big
organizations there are teams that are
kind of happening that are responsible
for handling different parts of the
system so there is one team that sort of
handles the front end maybe of the
system there's another team that sort of
it is logging and maybe a machine
learned some machine learning guys are
actually responsible for producing the
models and so on and these guys might
decide for instance that oh you're
logging too much data this is you know
hurting like performance we're going to
start dropping some information from log
and one of the things that we noticed
people like to drop a lot for one reason
or the other is these probabilities
because they cannot see for the life of
them why it's useful to law probably if
you want to actually do more careful
estimates here you don't just need this
one number but you actually need the
whole distribution if you want to give
out like confidence intervals and such
right so they that's often the first
thing that goes which is very
frustrating sometimes people log them
but then they even like somehow they
manage to come up with incorrect
probability so you'll sort of get a
purported probability somebody tells you
yeah this was done with uniform
randomization and then you can I mean
you can go and verify based on
frequencies of things that you know
whether this was the allegedly uniform
or not and you find out that no it's
very very non-uniform what you're seeing
in the data right so there's there's all
kinds of things that kind of go wrong
often one of the things that goes wrong
is that people have kind of people are
working at one level of stack in a very
complex system and there's all kinds of
downstream modifications that happen to
so so maybe you make a recommendation
then there is some special promotion
going on which says oh actually you know
what in the first slot you are always
going to put this promotional offer and
now what you recorded is the action
maybe that was taken after you did this
replacement and you ascribe the
probability that was for the suggested
action which was before this replacement
there
just like frustrating practical things
that come in the way so so so we've
invested quite a bit of our time kind of
discovering these bugs so at some point
we said okay this is getting kind of
intractable let's just try and build a
system ourselves which we'll try and
actually handle as many of these pieces
as possible
so that we know that they interoperate
correctly so that we know that the
information we need at the next layer is
recorded by the previous layer and so
that and that they are easy to use so
that we will actually don't go off and
do something different themselves yeah
that's kind of a funny one so you know
generally you want to use as much
information as you can to design useful
features so one thing if you have this
sort of probability sitting in the logs
sometimes people oh actually maybe this
will form a useful feature and that can
create some interesting bias problems so
you don't want to do that right so it's
just yeah so that was kind of the design
principle behind which which started
this project and so we wanted to keep
this whole system which is sort of in in
our minds handling the entire data
lifecycle and sometimes for instance
people might want to use a different
piece like a different logging subsystem
or a different type of learner so we did
want to make things modular as well so
that's that sort of being the the key
design principle and kind of the you
know utopian hope is that maybe for many
problems you can just come this so
automated and convenient that maybe you
can just take an ml person out of the
loop which means I have to answer your
emails right so we we as you're building
this these these guys from Emerson they
were looking for something to help them
with personalized recommendations for
users so it was very fortuitous timing
they came to us we work with them for a
while and eventually got deployed
and it's been running for about a year
and a half now or about a year now and
this is just like a small snapshot so so
obviously so the baseline was just kind
of here the baseline was very weak they
were just doing things kind of by by
hand before just human editors deciding
these are kind of interesting new
stories to display to everybody right
now but so over this baseline still you
see I mean but they change these things
pretty quickly so it's it's a human
baseline it's not a completely trivial
one but it's not personalized so we get
varying degrees of improvement across
different days but you know now this has
been in production for a really long
time and the gains are consistently
around like twenty to thirty percent on
average in the number of plagues and the
other interesting thing is like even
though we are driving a very kind of
immediate and maybe very coarse metric
like clicks we are finding improvements
in all other kinds of user engagement
metrics that we didn't actually optimize
for either and they've deployed these in
sort of multiple markets and multiple
segments and it keeps on kind of
yielding good results which is also a
very good robustness check for the
system so a little bit about the design
of the system now so a system
conceptually breaks into kind of three
big pieces so there is kind of this
piece that really is the piece that's
exposed to an application it's we call
it a client library although so it's
either provided as a c-sharp library or
you can just interact with it by making
Web API calls so it just it runs in the
inertia and you can just make a couple
of quick API calls
there is also kind of a JavaScript
version that's now coming out and so on
but but coarsely what happens is
whatever front-end application there is
a sense of context to this API the API
sends back a decision and then at a
later point when the reward information
becomes available it sends back a reward
along with the associated key for this
this context so that we know
this information has arrived and as the
information keeps arriving the the
information flows through a joint server
so you know because because kind of like
these things can arrive very
asynchronously you have to do some
joining later
and once you associate the the sort of a
complete context decision reward
probability topo you can pass it to a
learning layer we do try and update our
models actually online in real time that
was interesting about I understand
usually people get freaked out about
online learning but they they wanted to
I should respond to breaking news and
events like this so they were really
happy that we can do online learning and
we told them okay we'll sort of redeploy
a model every five minutes or so they
couldn't do online learning right in the
front end because you know that's just
like too heavy for a web server to do so
we said okay we'll deploy maybe a new
model every five minutes or so and that
kind of works well enough so we we're
sort of doing still some off policy
learning here right because we are not
constantly adapting but yeah so yeah and
then all of the exploration right
because this is where the decisions get
recommended so exploration happens in
this piece this piece handles the
correct logging learning and then the
deployment is just kind of the other
piece that that is kind of valuable
about actually having such a system is
so we stole all the data we are
collecting we store all the joint apples
also in an offline store just in the
cloud and because we've gathered this
data with exploration then they can kind
of like the usual things you would do
with machine learning right you want to
do your feature engineering hyper
parameter tuning whatever regularization
and algorithm selection you want you can
go you can do this offline like all of
your data science you can do here you
can transfer these findings back
whenever you want so so that kind of
like all of the classical things can
still be done but now you know that they
are counterfactually correct because
you're doing them in the in the correct
manner for off policy valuation so
that's kind of the difference between
the standard practice and doing it using
our system so the client library
like I said it's a currently the C++
library is a little bit out of date so
there's mostly there c-sharp and it's
very scalable it's extremely low latency
like MSN is using it in real time I
think it will have no trouble happening
handling big scale as well so it's
pretty scalable the Web API obviously
it's very easy to integrate with but
it's somewhat higher latency we we have
a few exploration schemes oh I forgot to
put our I love token bandits algorithm
here which is also implemented so we
have a few we have a few different
exploration schemes that are supported
we keep on adding them as we keep
finding new interesting things the john
service it's pretty simple it's just
sort of it's receiving streaming data
data arrives with so the data points
arrive each point has a different key
associated with it but maybe when you
receive a reward information about say
this green record it will have the same
key of course so you so whenever you see
kind of events with same key and you can
we allow sort of people to record
multiple rewards even though you might
be optimizing just one of them so that
you can also try experimenting with
reward functions offline so and there is
an experimental duration associated with
the deployment so once this duration
elapses then all the events with the
same key are joined together right so
that's just very simple semantics the
learning we are using basically existing
contextual bandit algorithms the I think
the nice thing from a practical
standpoint is so a lot of this thing
these things currently the way they
happen is people kind of they take some
data they do some counterfactual
incorrect learning with it then they are
forced to run a a B does to actually
verify whether their offline gains
translate to any offline improvement or
online improvement or not and
[Music]
anecdotally in even with good machine
learning these are
you know about like 20 to 30% at most
success rate of the AP tests so
basically whether like you're doing off
policy evaluation and and off policy
optimization properly or are you just
ignoring the fact that this information
came from us so for instance what you
can do right you you have recorded
clicks on certain events I I can just
treat this as a binary classification
problem run logistic regression
completely ignore the fact that some
events that these events have a
distribution that's influenced by my
behavior policy and that will be very
different from when I now use a
different model to drive things right so
whether you're taking this sort of
distributional shift into account or not
but yeah thanks for that clarifying
question right so basically the nice
thing is what we are giving is we are
giving estimates roughly that translate
to this if you ran this experiment last
week and and then you evaluate some
policy based on the data you've
collected then this says the this is
what your new policy would have done if
you had deployed it during that same
week right so that's that's kind of the
that's why it's a counterfactual
question that's being answered and we
can we can do this we can provide its
unbiased we can provide confidence
interval around it and so on so so so
that's nice because it saved you the
hassle of then what you came up with you
have to get through an a/b test now you
don't right so that's where it's kind of
a lot of saving of resources and time
and in particular it becomes really
important because then you have to a
beat as something you have to kind of
build it to a certain standard so that
you can actually expose it to user
traffic if you just have to like
evaluate something on a bunch of data
you have on your laptop I mean you can
go to party in whatever crappy
implementation you want to do right so
so it's really it can be more powerful
than you realize at the first blush and
then you could once you know you can
like there's only a little gap between
policy evaluation and policy
optimization so you can if you want
find the best policy from some set of
policies you can basically cast this as
a cost sensitive multi-class
classification problem and we have
algorithms to support that you can
update things online or batch all of
that works quite well so I just wanted
to give you some quick numbers to give
you sense of the scale as well as a
little bit about the simplicity so with
MSN we are still using by the way
epsilon video exploration is kind of
funny but it works reasonably well so
the setting there was that the context
was they would basically feature eyes
the users in terms of what they were so
they they create a topic model for for
every document and then a user's feature
vector is what are what are what is an
average of the topics of the documents
that you've read in say the past month
or past she roars right some average
over some time period and then obviously
if your actions feature vector is just
its own topic model and then so this way
you have a feature vector per action and
then they give us about 50 of these and
that's what we picked from and we are
handling pretty good amount of traffic
so they have tens of millions of users
and roughly thousands of requests per
second which we don't really have
trouble handling this is by the way also
where online learning is really nice
because you're just working over the
data in a streaming fashion it means you
don't need to you know run things in
parallel and clusters or anything you
can just handle things very scared of me
and we we also I mean we do use some
parallelism for like doing things like
joining and so on but training is
completely sequential and yeah works
quite well so there's a bunch of
resources there is a paper that actually
describes a lot of the system this is
this is this is the website where you
can go and you can start playing there's
some there's some test rice and
interactive guides and so on to to help
people get started it's it's actually
pretty pretty easy to get started with
much easier obviously for people in the
room because they shine everything
about machine learning not our typical
user and all of the learning almost all
of our learning technology is also in VW
and pretty much the entire system is by
the way open source so you know there's
very little sort of we are keeping
proprietary here obviously it's a cloud
service so if you want to use the that
service then you will eventually get
charged currently we are not even
charging there because we were just sort
of ironing out various kinks in our
system but but we have a few pilots for
instance ongoing mostly of a content
recommendation flavor and mostly things
seem kind of robust and working now so
so yeah if you have kind of interesting
ideas of things to do with it I think it
might be a good time to consider playing
with things because I think we have a we
have everything in a pretty reasonable
shape now and at least a lot of the
default sort of work out of the box and
if you have suggestions for how we might
improve things that would be amazing and
extremely welcome to so yeah I'll stop
there
[Applause]
we'll get a big fight to get management
hello
very strange group of people staring at
me taking pictures very popular
I'm hi so my name is sorry it is very
wild I guess that's right that's right
hi so my name is Lally I'm a postdoc at
the University of Michigan and last
couple of years I've been working on the
system for active learning called next
it kind of was a project that started at
Wisconsin and lots of people involved
with it it was originally an idea of
Kevin Jamison's who was a grad student
at Wisconsin at the time is now a
postdoc here at Berkeley Rob's been of
course very involved with that and
there's just been tons of other people I
mentioned Scott Seaford up there because
he's currently a grad student at
Wisconsin who's who's done a lot of
development so let me go say a few words
about next this talks a little bit
different from Alex because I'll kind of
mention you know a lot of application in
the system and so let's let's begin so
like you know we've had this week's been
great and I'd love to thank the
organizers for kind of holding this and
I've enjoyed seeing all these talks and
a lot of the talks we've seen this piece
where it's like here's this active
learning algorithm and then we went on a
mechanical turk and we gathered a bunch
of data and here's kind of how you know
we get our nice plots at the end and
like the random curve is hopefully under
the active curve and everybody's really
happy and but the thing about that right
is like so what we get to see in these
toxins is this kind of nice few boxes we
get to see an algorithm and then we get
to see this part where it's like hey you
want to add a bunch of participants but
as we all probably know there's kind of
this challenging part in the middle
right like you if you're gonna have
these people on Mechanical Turk
answering these questions and trying to
evaluate these algorithms you need to
create some nice webpage for them you
need to be able to monitor your
experiment make sure it's doing
something reasonable
how about traffic right so like for
example if you put out too many hits on
Mechanical Turk if too many people are
coming to your website at the same time
maybe your site will go down right like
it's hard to kind of keep a low latency
side up you obviously need store your
solutions and you and you know most
importantly you need to have some huge
computational back-end and you need to
manage all of this and this is kind of
the components in doing something
real-time in the crowd right this is the
real-time computational system and the
tree doesn't matter is that
your algorithm is kind of just the start
of this whole story if you want to
implement one of these things in the
wild it takes a decent amount of effort
so how you know how does this process
look for people when they try to
actually do this well they start with
the algorithm and then you decide that
you need a server and a database and
maybe you know like celery and RabbitMQ
you like build all these little tools in
for kind of monitoring tasks so you can
handle like initially you might handle
five users now you can handle ten users
etc you go create a group of grad
students there the big ones undergrad
students the small ones to implement all
of this for you these guys get it
working it's running on laptops
everybody's really happy with it then
you realize you want to do in the wild
so you know some learning happens people
go out there they learn what Amazon's
ec2 is how to like put stuff on cloud
computing they store some information
there's more and more acronyms that pop
up maybe at some point somebody that's
it's like wonderful idea of like hey
let's containerized everything like you
know well let's use technologies right
everybody loves technology and then at
some point a couple months later you you
deploy this you go to Amazon Mechanical
Turk you recruit these participants you
do your experiment you write your paper
and you know maybe things are running
and you're really happy with it and six
months later down the road doctor
changes its version this actually
extremely recently happened to us where
a doctor changes its version and now no
longer everything works and you'd love
to like you know go call these guys to
help you out but unfortunately they're
like at their new cool startup that
implements active learning algorithms so
like you're I think this is like not
uncommon story and I think for I think
it's happened a lot it's kind of hard to
build these systems right it's hard to
it's it's not too bad to kind of build
something you can kind of get up quickly
and running it's kind of hard to build
something you can kind of reuse over and
over again and so next the system we've
come up with and you can kind of see it
at next emmelda org tries to fix this
issue so as I mentioned there's lots of
people involved in it and we tried to
build a very general-purpose system for
you to implement active learning
algorithms and and so I'll take the rest
of this talk and basically show you guys
a short demo of how it looks how it
works and talk about kind of some of the
success stories we've had or the last
couple years using next so research
first kind of start off by saying you
know who who's next really aimed at
and it's kind of the whole spectrum so
on one end it's researchers right like
machine learning research you want to
test their algorithms about to leave was
talking yesterday about how their Force
Research Lab use an extra active image
classification but then there's a lot of
experimental lists who might be kind of
on the more for in in our case we've
seen worked with a lot of psychologists
a lot of sociologists so some of you
probably met James Evans here who's here
for most of the week and then Donna who
are using next to kind of do some
adaptive data collection and various
sociological for some very sociological
questions and then you know at the very
other end of the spectrum there's people
in industries for example we help the
New Yorker kind of do this data
collection where they have this
captioning contest I'll talk a little
bit more about that so I'll come back to
that but the point is it's kind of we
try to really create a tool that we feel
that everybody can use so one question
we often get is kind of you know into
something a mind clarify early is like
you know what what applications can next
really support like which specific
active learning in class big
applications you can do and I think it's
worth kind of breaking that question
down so there's applications so for
example there's class of a
classification task right or like a
ranking task or a best arm
identification task and for all these
applications we have many algorithms
that we could try to implement in any
algorithms we could use and it's
important to have the ability to kind of
evaluate these different algorithms for
any given task you want to do right even
if you're just even if you're just doing
some research you have a new algorithm
you probably want to test this against
older algorithms in a real life setting
so next is very much based around this
idea that you have one main learning
application and you kind of plug and
play algorithms into that application
and it kind of you know it's really
designed to kind of facilitate this
plugging and playing of different
algorithms so to get back to this
question and you know what applications
came next really support kind of out of
the box we can do a whole bunch of
things we have algorithms implemented
for contextual bandits various bandit
applications reclassification
applications ordinal embedding Adam
kalaiy earlier this week spoke about
crowd kernel that's one application
we've played a lot with various kind of
linear bandit techniques but the truth
of the matter is is that if you're
interested in want to try to use it for
any
thing else you could you could pretty
much implement anything you want and
I'll talk a little bit about what it
takes to implement something new and
next as I go along
so I'll just say yeah let me let me say
one more kind of yeah let me take one
more quick word about like what what
this takes and the point is is that when
you're designing one of these systems to
do active learning there's there's a lot
on the slide well kind of just say
quickly you're designing one of these
systems to do active learning really the
parts you only want to implement are
what it takes to kind of start up an
experiment right so if you're doing some
kind of bandit multi-armed bandit
problem you know you want to be able to
specify half and bandit
maybe there's some feature vectors
associated with them or something like
this but then you also just want to be
able to specify information around how
do you get a query so if a new
participant comes to your experiment how
can they request a query how you kind of
process the answer around that query and
in the background you have some process
that's running to constantly update your
model whether you're doing that after
every query you're doing that in some
kind of batch job and you also need to
have some ability to get the models so
for example in a bestower modification
process you should have a way to kind of
get the best time and see confidences
around that arm and so in the next
system this picture is a little bit
complicated but basically all that
happens is these queries the crowd
requests the query we basically have
some system set up to handle lots and
lots of simultaneous requests this kind
of goes to this algorithm manager so
again under this this model that we can
kind of handle multiple algorithms at
the same time your code kicks in so
somehow the only part you really have to
worry about is kind of implementing
these kinds of five functions especially
the get query process answer an update
model and then we can send the query all
the way back out so for example if it's
some kind of triplet task that's how
that would look and similar with the
process answer but the thing I'm really
trying to kind of emphasize here is that
when you do want to implement something
indexed it really is as easy as like you
you literally open up a file with these
three functions in it and you can just
kind of implement those there so I want
to do a quick demo and I encourage
people to try this on their phones yeah
so for active learning the semantics of
jQuery can I seem more obvious is very
basically an action if you work doing
the contextual bandit or bestowment the
identification type a query is when a
user comes to your application what
question you're gonna ask them yeah sure
or you present them with an arm and they
you know respond with the reward and the
triplets problem it's you show them some
triplet and you ask them to kind of
answer that question classification it's
some kind of maybe I am and does this do
you have any assumptions or restrictions
on sort of the life latency of this
process does it have to be kind of if
you have a query does the user have to
answer right away and information sort
of come come back to you at a my
information came back whenever so I'll
say so I'll make two comments about that
one because the system is very flexible
how you choose to process those queries
and in what order is up to you so for
example if you want to do something
totally random and update a model at the
end you can do that if you want if you
want to kind of decide that hey every
time I get a new hundred ones in I'm
going to do process kind of a batch of a
hundred that's also up to you as well
but I'm curious about how how do you
deal with it for the things that you
have implemented because like one thing
you have to kind of be careful about in
the setting is right this itself can
sometimes cause a bias like if you have
that easy examples maybe user just
answers right away harder ones are
answered with a maybe higher latency so
then if I just sort of process things as
they come yeah I don't think we in any
of our applications we're really
addressing that issue specifically but
you could so for example like with this
joint system yeah yeah so be interesting
kind discuss how to implement that one
thing that we I mean a lot of
applications like for example these
kernel bandit applications the main
thing we try to do is just make sure we
have some kind of extremely like you
know you want to give these queries out
as fast as
possible and I think in our a lot of our
applications there isn't as much maybe
it's a little bit different from
ad-serving in that case because for a
lot of our applications so far the way
it's worked is very much the query goes
out people respond back and we're much
more interested in low latency queries
and high throughput at a given time
because it is something like a
Mechanical Turk experiment so I think
maybe that you know we don't have some
drift over time that we have to worry
about as much exactly super interesting
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely yeah so
it'd be fun if people want to try this
so next ml dark slash Simon's an XML org
slash caption content so I put up two
kind of experiments and let me go to
them so for example here's one of a
triplet tasks
so basically sorry the instructions are
extremely small up there but select the
face on the bottom are topped as the
closest and most emotional expression to
the face on the top right so this is the
kind of thing I was talking about I
think that's a really hardcore you're
talking about so let's say maybe this
one because I don't know sad is a little
bit closer I don't know what that faces
and so we can answer these questions I
think back one do people agree something
like this yeah these are tough and the
point is is that you have kind of two
components here one is you can ask these
these queries and in the back next also
provides you with a lot of tools for
kind of monitoring this experiment so
again they're all these issues kind of
around latency and things like that so
we give you ways to kind of tracked you
know for every time one of these queries
is asked how long does that take how
does it take the process the answer how
long does it kind of take to update the
model etc and you can also kind of build
in statistics so if people are kind of
interested in doing this task if anybody
does it we can look at the end and see
what kind of embedding we get from these
important embedding questions so
another task and I mentioned kind of
alluded to before is kind of this New
Yorker task so this is I guess this
week's cartoon that we're judging so so
the idea and this cartoon contest is the
New Yorker every week has they do this
caption contest and the cartoon goes out
there to the wild when people send in
captions right and so they get about
5000 of these captions every week and
they need to decide the funniest one and
so we've been helping them using next to
kind of address that so for heaven's
sake it's just gluten it's actually kind
of funny
I'll get it a somewhat funny anyways and
so we basically rank these 5,000
captions and give them an answer every
week this is fine but so it's kind of an
example of some of the things you can
you can do with next so so let me um for
the rest of the talk I just kind of want
to talk about some of the people who are
using it so as I mentioned before Neera
captured caption contest has been one
the big ones so this is something so Bob
Bob man cough the cartoon editor at The
New Yorker came to us looking for a
system to do this and I think every week
we get around 15 to 20 thousand people
who kind of go on to the site we collect
around half a million to three quarters
and million responses and Ervin who's
here at the conference as well has kind
of been working on improving some of
these algorithms and one thing we've one
thing that's been really great about
this is we've implemented various
adaptive algorithms like well used to be
for for this task and we've seen kind of
pretty quickly we did so we've gathered
about a year of data at this point and
some we're kind of early on I think
after 20 contests or so we kind of asked
this question which was you know I think
there was like a series of contests
where basically the editor didn't really
look at the dashboards and we kind of
had him use his old process before he
was using an axe to kind of pick the
caption and then we are also character
collecting these queries using this
little UCB method and this random method
and we tried to see you know how often
is the winning caption kind of in the
top 10 and I think this was based off of
10 or 15 captions and you can kind of
see that like with far fewer queries on
probability that it would be in the top
10 for a little ucv was significantly
higher than it was for random so this
was one of the kind of first real
successes he saw and it was nice to see
that there was kind of a win on adaptive
data collection so again I use all our
notes embedding experiment they I just
want to say a few more words about this
because this has been definitely one of
the places where we really used next
heavily so Jerry a few years back he
came up with this data set called the
strange or this the sequence of images
the strange fruit images and the idea is
is that it's some kind of one parameter
family that goes from something
extremely spiky to something that's not
so spiky and the way these these images
were kind of cooked up is so that like
between any two of them it's kind of at
the threshold of like human perception
between any two of them I for one cannot
tell the difference between like any of
those four but people tell me there are
small differences but we went out and we
asked this we did this triplet task on
Mechanical Turk to kind of see you know
if we ask these triplet comparisons
these are no embedding comparisons can
we recover this one-dimensional manifold
that these shapes are lying on so and we
did this using several different kind of
data collection animal algorithms we use
various active data collection
algorithms we use just kind of random
sampling we used various objectives for
how to actually get the embedding once
you knew the triplets and we got we were
able to kind of use next to create this
nice kind of grid of all the
possibilities so these are various the
rows correspond to various adaptive
algorithms and the call of the
correspond to various embedding
techniques here's the crowd kernel
method that Adam talked about and I do
think you know we we felt that crowd
kernel kind of had the best quality
embedding you very much kind of
recovered this line and what was
interesting about this though is that
even though you kind of get the embed
the embeddings where you might be
interested in saying you know did active
really outperform random in this problem
and what we noticed was by measuring so
we went out and gathered a lot of these
triplets and we kind of asked what was
the generalization error on some kind of
holdout set of the resulting embedding
so you you gather a bunch of triplets
you learn an embedding you test on the
whole on a holdout set of triplets to
see how well you did and what we what we
kind of notice we didn't really see a
gain on generalization from air
from doing this active sampling approach
and this was a very interesting thing to
us because you know there's a lot of
techniques out there at this point for
doing for active strategies to this
problem so I think it's kind of a very
interesting area of research and how do
you do this ordinal embedding problem
actively and I'd love to kind of see
more experiments out there kind of
active versus passive sampling on this
problem so that's kind of one betting
problem and a little bit more on the
applied side of the ordinal embedding
problem one of our partners on this has
been Tim Rogers who's a cognitive
psychologist at uw-madison and he's very
interested in this this emotion task
that I showed you guys before so maybe
we'll get a picture like that at the end
if anybody does it and maybe we won't
but basically you can go out there and
ask is the emotion and face I more like
the emotion and face J or emotion in
face K it's very and one of the things
that's kind of been around since the 70s
in cognitive psychology models this is
like circular model of emotion I don't
understand this particularly well but
from what I understand is like the
correct somehow embedding or
representation of emotions should go
from happiness on one end to kind of you
know fear and anger kind of on opposite
ends and things should arise in a circle
so we went out and collected a lot of
Triplets of this form using some kind of
adapted data tech collection technique
and we were pretty excited to see that
we were able to compute the embedding
and recover kind of this conjectured
circle in the cognitive psychology
literature and in general I think for a
lot of the people we work with who are
psychologists and sociologists and kind
of in the humanities
they're extremely interested in how can
you do adaptive data collection faster
and you know does it work do you
actually see the games or games over
random so this was kind of a fun
experiment to try with them along these
lines Blake Mason who's a year
Martyna Rao also Martinez in the
educational psychology department at
Wisconsin and Blake's for Pasadena Bob's
they kind of did a very similar
experiment with chemistry data molecules
so they went to a chemistry class and
they basically said you know here's
here's kind of a triplet of three
molecules which of the bottom two
molecules is closest to the top molecule
and they try to create an embedding and
the goal of understanding getting these
kinds of features is eventually to try
to work towards
to work towards personalized tutoring
system so in this case they want to
gathered a bunch of these queries from
this chemistry class and you know you
get some kind of embedding back in some
kind of clustering that's not so
unrealistic from the point of view of
chemistry I don't know anything about
chemistry I also suspect it might just
be because like you know all these are
like cyclic hydrocarbons they do all
kind of look alike right so it's not
it's not immediately clear you know what
what's kind of being perceived here but
it's nice to I think for them it's nice
to be able to use next as a tool to run
a lot of the experiments gather data and
try to understand something about
perception in these contexts so I'll
mention kind of flip flipping back to a
use of next that's happening in industry
right now another partner we've had is
American Family Insurance so this is
Devin he's uh works at AM fan and one
thing he's been using next for is
they're very interested in kind of doing
document tagging and kind of sentiment
analysis on documents and having active
algorithms to do this so they basically
use some active classification
techniques and they go out there and
they basically you know before people
log into their computers every morning
once they get to work they answer one or
two questions and so it's things like
you know they'll show people a claim
note and they'll say does the following
claim note mention the concept of a
rental car so they're trying to build a
classification a classifier for whether
a document would have the phrase rental
car or something like this or you know
what is the sentiment of this note
things of this form and so they've been
kind of playing around with necks and
trying various kind of internal ways of
using it the next task this has been a
project that's kind of going on in Rob's
group is around personalized image
search
so the idea and this is they worked with
the Zappos 50k data set and if I
understand correctly the idea of this
project was they're basically trying to
do some kind of image search tasks so
you're given some starting kind of
primary image so like a red boot and
they were using various kind of awful
linear banded techniques to ask you know
ask questions about is this shoe that
you see similar to the red boot that you
started off or not so they use next on
this and the kinds of queries were of
this form like you know
they tell people the kind of crime
people in town pick things that look
like red boots and they keep showing
them shoes and they use various active
algorithms and they it was it was a very
interesting experiment and one thing
that they ended up finding is that if
you kind of looked at how in terms of
some kind of search retrieval error or
some yeah in terms of some kind of
retrieval reward system these kinds of
active algorithms which are kind of up
here perform significantly better than
just using some form of nearest neighbor
retrieval on various cafe features so
this yeah so there was kind of an
interesting experiment they were able to
apply active learning in this world of
image search and kind of a kind of an
interesting awful way but I I don't know
a ton about the details of the
experiment so I'm gonna go a ton into it
but I'm happy to put you in touch with
people who did it
so but it was a kind of another example
of a nice application of next so let me
kind of I also wanted to mention lis
here so Lee's been using next heavily at
their first research lab the way he
mentioned yesterday and so you guys
couldn't talk with him if you're kinda
interested in how they're doing it and
they're they have a lot of resources so
they get to run around really huge
machines with lots of people
simultaneously it's super cool so I just
kind of want to finish off and basically
say that let you know what's been nice
about next for us is kind of there's
there's a nice cycle here that we work
on it we develop it we get to try our
own algorithms on it and this really
kind of informs others I think you know
there's for a lot of the projects I
mentioned before I've kind of mentioned
only the first step when we ran the
experiments there's for almost all of
them there's been like second and third
step with the experiment right got ran
people are able to take that data
develop new theory around it run more
experiments there's a lot of iteration
that happens and then that feeds into
you know these experimentalists we
really do want to use that these
psychologists sociologists we've been
working with and it's kind of you know
filtered this way all the way into
industry and kind of come back to us and
we've been extremely excited that the
cycles happened it's helped us make next
better and it's helped others kind of
collect the data they want to collect so
I'll just kind of finish up Sario
running a little long time so I'll get a
fish up this is the current next team so
Kevin Rob Scott Seiver Rudy
who are all it was huntin and what
Kevin's came here and I and so you know
if you have any questions feel free to
so sounds good thanks yeah yes the the
sight of things relevant to researchers
that you talked about mostly is where I
have an algorithm and then to sort of I
can use the system which reduces a lot
of complexity for me but I still have to
sort of go and get my own crowd and pay
for them and so on right collecting some
very sort of valuable data in all of
these things doing so I'm curious about
is if you actually go to the website
there are links to places where we
created some data repositories so that
all the New Yorker data is available and
I think a lot of the Triplett's data is
available as well to follow up to that
question is is there sort of collected
and recorded in a way that so one thing
that's again very tricky often with
practical practical actual learning is
that if I kind of changed my algorithm
it might justify the strategies that
you're employing to collect and then
make it easy to do some of these off
policy type things or yeah for the most
part I mean we're so there's a couple
things I mean one thing is is that again
everything in next like it's very
reproducible like if you run an
experiment you can kind of run the same
thing again you're right that the data
you've collected has changed but a lot
of the data collections we're doing
we're kind of trying to ensure that
we're also getting you know everything
is extremely time stamped you know
exactly which participant was kind of
involved in the answering of that query
which algorithm that query kind of came
from but we also make sure that at least
for the data collects we've released
there's some random data it's also
collected so the policies vary a lot so
but on every single one of these
experiments and they've all been very
much like evaluation experiments right
like I think when
work with somebody I would never
recommend you go straight to an active
algorithm kind of in the short run
because that's like what the Triplett's
thing it's not clear to me that there's
actually a gain an adaptive gain
so why bias your why bias your collect
so I does that answer a question yeah
yeah so all that's kind of easy to use
and you can kind of get it out of the
system extremely easily so yeah
yeah you can do whatever you want so
basically the way it's set up right
that's that's a good question cuz a lot
of people want to build pretty elaborate
UIs it's all just kind of done in
standard HTML and JavaScript and it's
kind of everything's been very like it's
been very designed to just be kind of
plug-and-play so you can kind of you
design your UI decide exactly what
interface you want to use in terms of
how you want it to kind of connect to
your algorithm like where you want that
data flow to go you specify all of that
explicitly and either some yeah Mille or
JSON file so yeah it's like it's like
you know if you've ever had to code very
long or something it's like you very
much like tie up inputs and outputs and
then everything is kind of just
generated for you so it's it's pretty
flexible when it comes to things like
that and that's what allows us like just
kind of going back to these dashboards
to like that's kind of what allows for
these dashboards you know so like for
the example the New Yorker wanted a very
different UI from the thing we kind of
just had built in which is much more
simple looking right so it's it's easy
to do so curious to know if this
embedding did anything sorry
doesn't look like it but we probably
need some more data
yeah well I don't know those two might
belong together it's hard to tell so
anyways but the point is you can kind of
add any of these vigil elements that you
want waiting yes so this has actually
been kind of tricky so here's what
here's what we can do well right now and
to do anything more you'd have to add on
what we can do well is is that the
minute you kind of show up so for
example the minute you show up to this
page we return some identifier that
belongs to you on every single session
the thing we do not do is we don't like
on every single query so we don't create
sessions right now to kind of track who
you are so if you refresh this page
you're a totally different user from the
point of view of the system but like
that's one of the modifications you know
like that's it wouldn't be difficult to
do that system or tagged by this user
yes yes it's tagged by this user and so
you have tracked all that you have the
timestamp you know exactly when they got
the query you know exactly when they
clicked on that thing when they returned
it and you can do anything else so there
was some team I think it was the am fam
team who are actually trying to do this
with some eye tracking software and some
mouse tracking software kind of thing
and one thing about all of this that I
didn't say and I should should kind of
emphasize those along one slide I
skipped here was just like at the end of
the day you have all of this kind of UI
but it is just a REST API so very
similar to kind of kind of this
Microsoft service there's some REST API
there and so for example for The New
Yorker they don't even really use our
kind of UI they're just doing some
request through their servers so they're
able to track users because they have
the infrastructure setup to do sessions
and things so it's kind of infinitely
flexible there in terms of that kind of
thing so
Thanks
[Applause]